[Musique]
voilà des bons ballons en touche les
manchots monsieur je voudrais un corner
de marrons monsieur ses fallas mais je
suis sûr fallas pour moi vous savez des
hameaux non monsieur je pense possible
de ne pas le connaître votre nom depuis
deux jours dans paris on ouvre n'importe
quel journal on entend parler de
monsieur ses fallas le marchand marron
qui fait des tableaux le marchand de
tableaux qui fait du marron quand on
ouvre le poste de radio on entend parler
de monsieur ses fallas quand on ouvre la
télévision on entend parler de monsieur
ses fallas vous êtes déjà un homme
célèbre alors comment vouliez-vous que
j'ignore votre nom à brescia monsieur je
suis stupéfié volume a jusque chez
d'être déjà célèbre alors écoutez
monsieur ses fallas ne soyez plus
stupéfaits et parlons de choses
sérieuses
vous vendez les marrons depuis combien
de temps je parle démarrant depuis à la
même place laroche est 4h02 les bolides
depuis 25 ans depuis 25 ans vous avez
durant vendre démarreur oui des tonnes
et des tonnes des wagons et des wagons
en démarrant mais alors à qui les
vendent et vous est-ce que vous avez une
clientèle spéciale
non pas du tout mais je ne vais pas je
vends tout ça a au passage sur toutes
les midinettes
les vendeurs des grands magasins elle
aimait nazaire qui passe pour acheter
dans les grands magasins de la rue de
rivoli
alors les enfants ne mangent pas de
harbin attendu surtout léger dit elle et
elle les samedis et les dimanches du
mois aux enfants alors un dimanche ou un
jour comme aujourd'hui ça marche le
marron samarth seulement qu' à partir de
5 hier quand les uns il commence à
sortir de cinéma et de théâtre
oui alors maintenant maintenant il est
trois heures et quart et les marrons ne
se vend pas non justement vous êtes le
premier client qui vous estimez marron
là vous me les avait toujours pas donné
moi j'ai un qu'est ce que je fais il
doit maintenant vous vous êtes mis à la
peinture
comment vous êtes vous mis à la banda a
jamais mis à la peinture depuis cinq ans
seulement
après d'une grande maladie que j'ai eus
je suis allé dans une petite maisonnette
aisée dans la vallée de chevreuse et là
je vous remets d'istres et j'ai commencé
à mélanger les peintures après on m'a
découvert que je suis un peintre choses
que j'ignorais complètement
alors est-ce que le marron vous êtes
vous a inspiré en matière de peinture
pour des natures mortes
pourtant j'ai pas vu beaucoup de marrons
dans vos tableaux vesa feriel ilan a
déjà il en a surtout justement il en a
un qu'il a été exposé au salon d'automne
à 1957 et ses tableaux l'ajustement
qu'il a dit qui m'a lancé convaincre
mais ce que vous peignez dans des
teintes chaudes non non non non alors
les marrons chauds les teintes chaudes
en vacances on pas dit ou même pas du
tout monsieur monsieur ses fallas
lorsque vous vendez vos marron est-ce
que vous rêvez a d'autres choses à la
peinture par exemple monsieur vraiment
su base et pense à ma peinture est géré
ma peinture jarrell ma clientèle
de la journée et le soir je pense
apprenant cette ferme silhouette de
différents clochard qui passe devant moi
parce que je suis dans les périmètres t
elle les adore tous ces mecs les harkis
qui m'entourent qui redonne démarrant
gratuitement et je pense beaucoup à sept
personnages c'est pour ça que dans tous
mes tableaux d'ailleurs vous allez
remarquer que je n'ai toujours un pauvre
malheureux dans mes tableaux
[Musique]